you know what's funny it's the first
thing you look up on Zillow is something
that is in your price range and within
two seconds you're like 45 million you
know what I hate about those houses is
they'll only have like don't only have
like three pictures it's like come on
let me see all right how you doing it's
bill burr what's going on I'm driving a
car through Hollywood you probably first
thing you're thinking is Bill what's
with the Hollywood shades I'll tell you
what it is it's a big day out here in
Hollywood all the nominations for the
Golden Globes came out today and I want
to give a shout out to the Golden Globes
for standing strong and not nominating
any women until they [ __ ] earning
zero nominations for me it's right I
like I like the Golden Books they're old
school you know awards and credit or
ferment okay we started this business
you think you're just gonna waltz in
here and take our awards it ain't
happening
I can't believe people get upset about
that stuff can you believe Mandy
Mumford didn't get nominated for Marissa
Miranda right I mean what is going on
polar ice caps are melting stay focused
people and I even get nominated I mean I
like to think that I put out some pretty
solid dick and [ __ ] jokes this year I
didn't get a call
nobody came looking for old freckles
today we're going to Glendale Glendale I
believe is a town within Greater Los
Angeles it has a high Armenian
population as a giant mall has one of
the most incredible cemeteries you could
ever go to like if you're gonna [ __ ]
die all right
and you're all sad about it if they
showed you where they were gonna bury
you it would take a little bit of the
edge off depending on your age you know
if you were really young and still be
sad if you were super old you'd be like
I remember we used to fight engines over
there I gotta take something that the
highways out here it's not even the
traffic it's just the overgrown [ __ ] on
the side of the roads this is when
you're reminded that you live in a
desert
you know Clint Eastwood should be riding
a [ __ ] horse through there chapped
lips here's a part of Glendale a lot of
people don't see a lot of people come
down here they go to the mall okay they
go down and they get you know their name
or their loved ones names engraved on
some Crocs you know some sort of classy
Christmas gift you know uggs with your
baby's face made in fur around your calf
so everybody knows how much you care
you know what's [ __ ] gross is designer
clothes for toddlers you know what are
you doing they're gonna [ __ ] outgrow
it how much can you flaunt your [ __ ]
wilth crab Avenue it's an unfortunate
name
STD Lane get your [ __ ] crabs here now
this is like a great area too because
now you're you're north of the 134 so
all the animals down there at the Steak
and Shake Shake Shack all of those
[ __ ] people dead down there where
they belong on the other side on the
highway then you get up here look at
this they got an urgent care Urgent Care
people for when you know their gardener
cuts off his finger or something this is
where they send him I don't sorry I'm a
little out of sorts I can't believe
nobody with a vagina got nominated for a
Golden Globe I mean it's just
I'm gonna have a tough time today I
didn't even know they let women on TV to
be honest with you all right this is the
deal wherever you go in the world all
right then I'm gonna take off my glasses
see know that I'm being sincere here all
right
regular people live on flat land you
know if they got the church there you
know God won't you be up in them Hills
right and they just slide on right look
at okay see some [ __ ] people just
stacked up on top of people okay and
this is the deal you know that you've
made it in life when when you drive to
your house you're going up a hill that's
it you go up a hill you go into your
house and you look down on people see
the Ralph's is down here the rouse isn't
up there they don't want you up there
because you're not good enough okay and
you know when you're good enough you
know when you're good enough someday
when you could afford to tent one of
these [ __ ] houses up here
when you can risk having your toddler
get snatched by a coyote that's when you
know you may be alright so again we're
getting to the hills here see there's a
nicer apartments let's see what we got
going on here
look at that solar panels there's a guy
who cares yeah or a lady doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the Golden Globes thinking
about the polar ice caps is there way
for me to get some solar panels out of
this [ __ ] gig see little little puffy
part poodle dogs that's another time
when you know you're getting into wealth
when people have a poodle mix scene I
like these that's an old style house
Walter there's one you know you have an
old style house when they have a carport
carports like the one of the great
things that went away all right look at
that this guy's only your home is your
castle look at that he's got that little
[ __ ] snow cone up there then you got
the Brady Bunch style houses down here
there's no outlet you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how does LA know it just [ __ ] knows
what you're trying to do it just [ __ ]
knows I love when they [ __ ] you know
you [ __ ] alright that kids up to no
good
you see that kid leather jacket these
goddamn punks
oh god now this guy's gonna [ __ ] hate
me I'm just gonna pull right in here see
that's the move that's the move right
there
got out of his way he started to curse
me you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] with
this
oh sorry go ahead Jesus Christ that's
that scary kid what's he doing
good-looking guy he's all by himself
[ __ ] Bill Bixby walk into a new town
alright so now you got some of the older
styles I love look at that look at that
look at that that Mediterranean style
with the and all the woodwork of the
arches I'm a sucker for an arch look at
that guy he's got a little trickle truck
there for his horses this is the ugliest
house I've ever [ __ ] seen what is
that that's not looks like a kid did it
with Legos all right now we start
getting up here now what are these
houses go for over here Andrew yeah I'm
checking the Zillow app right now
we're in the 1 to 3 million dollar range
3 million bucks you see that we just
went up to the hill just a little bit
look at the [ __ ] the third little pig
built that one you don't see a lot of
brick houses out here
this guy's living the life here huh he's
got a modest house he's got an old
school two toned look at that badass
right there that's a beaut okay here we
go now we're getting up to we're getting
up to like 2.5 million dollars you see
this here chain-link fence you can look
through somebody's gonna build a house
there the Zillow app says that a lot was
200,000 he's gonna slam something in
there unless this person was smart
enough to buy it
they're so antisocial is that a
Volkswagen Scirocco cars lived forever
of you said what the [ __ ] that is that's
a Volkswagen Scirocco I haven't seen one
though since high school Jaguar we got a
little challenger here look at look at
the cars it's an old school something
what is it your [ __ ] books another
Volkswagen Scirocco two on the same
street is the gingerbread style house
you like one of those I'm sure you gain
weight when you have a house that looks
like a gingerbread house you just feel
like you have to be eating stuff with
frosting on it would it be redundant if
a ginger bought a gingerbread house
look at this Columbus they're not
ashamed they're not ashamed what he had
to do to discover a new world where
people were already yet I got to tell
you for the hills these are some
ugly-ass houses look at that damn thing
bought a la houses you know if you don't
buy like one of those old school ones
it's really about what it looks like
inside so this is basically the the
Beverly Hills of Glendale Beverly Hills
interestingly enough also has a flat
area and then it has up into the hills
look at that view come on you could
literally like parasail down to your
flight out of Burbank Airport get one of
those squirrel suits
say goodbye to your wife ah [ __ ] you
lady you never supported me and then you
just come in and just land right at you
[ __ ] fly
I'm sorry sir you have to take off that
suit before you go through I've got
nothing on underneath we can make an
exception
you got downtown la look at this person
here look at the [ __ ] view this
person has that's probably like 1.8
million dollars this guy can watch the
entire Valley burn every year in
September go that guy with his giant RV
it's as big as his [ __ ] house oh look
at that monstrosity being built over
there a big dog has moved in and he is
peeing all over the side of the canyon
and you know what everybody in these
smaller houses are doing that's
obnoxious why would you why would you
want all of that space and then you know
what he's gonna do he's gonna throw a
[ __ ] Christmas party and invite
everybody over right and then they're
all gonna love them how do we get up to
those people can I get up there this way
this how nice those houses are
whispering is there a way to get up
there oh that's right Andrew you have to
tell me they got a gate they got a gate
they're in Port be getting three million
bucks or this house here that's one of
those phony new ones but it's not new
once again the ugliest house I've ever
seen right there there it is that looks
like you know when you you remember at a
golf course you know that's like you
know low-level town they just have that
one-story thing lockers are on one side
wives on the other side mistresses in
the middle all right look at this you
can walk her kid feel safe and that's
the actual mom walking the kid you don't
see that lot you don't see that a lot in
Hollywood
Glendale these are real people out here
see she actually lives in the flatlands
and then she goes up the hills to get a
little bit exercise to get the baby
weight off okay but then she you know
what happens you know what happens
andrew is she sees too much she sees
these nice houses and it creates you
know I want to have
I want a wraparound deck you know and
that her husband feels that tightness in
his chest
yes some day honey someday who do you
get you a real estate advice from I get
it from that guy who talks about his
deck down at the funny bone
the Glendale Hills everybody you get
everything that everybody out in LA
wants you get a big house in the hills
with a view for a great old price you
buy a [ __ ] lot for 200 grand go go do
that in Beverly Hills see what that cost
you it'd be funny in his head I won and
neon lights up there local news media
would come why do you have that sign
because I want what does that mean so
you think that having the most property
brings happiness it does look at you you
you felt the need to come up here and
interview me I didn't come down and talk
to you I'm having a great time I want I
don't need a Golden Globe sorry
[Laughter]
Zillow everybody
[Music]